good morning john so i know that you
aren't super active on twitter though
also you are a little more active on
twitter than you used to be so welcome
back i
i do appreciate seeing you every once in
a while john green actor this is a
button by the way where like you can
follow a topic
so you are a topic on twitter john
you're just a inaccurate one and no
i do not follow the john green topic so
it's just a little too much to
follow my brother as a topic but twitter
twitter twitter twitter twitter twitter
twitter people
so so like there is a there's an active
discussion going on
about whether or not the right thing to
do is to abandon the platform which i
understand
it does not bring a ton of joy into my
life it's a stressful place and i think
that it
heightens my emotions and it does that
to everyone else and at the moment i
don't know that
heightened emotions seem to be helping
maybe they are
it's not clear i get told sometimes by
people
like we aren't gonna fix twitter
without leaving twitter i hear your
argument
i don't think that it's works because i
think that twitter
remains a tremendously important
cultural force
wither without me and it is possible
though unfortunate
for a place to be both apocalyptically
bad
and vital and necessary and unavoidable
because i don't like i think that i can
be
on twitter and i know that you may
disagree with me on this john
i think i can be on twitter and be
bringing
some perspective to the platform about
how to use it better
the norms of twitter have changed
uh and i think that they can continue to
change and maybe they will change in
ways
that will make us better at this i
haven't seen any real evidence of this
for clarity we're still bad at it every
day there are a bunch of trending topics
and they seem to be
the most hot thing possible
portrayed in the hottest possible life
and if there isn't something to get hot
about
someone will manufacture it they'll find
it they'll find something from
four years ago or this was one last week
spare thought
for the billions of people who will
never exist as world population growth
slows
the never conceived are the ultimate
forgotten ones
this article at least if you click on it
from twitter is behind a paywall
if i google it i can read it so that's
so all you get if you're on twitter is
the headline and the subhead that's
world population growth slows the never
conceived
or the old of course like the
your thought that you are having right
now is the thought that everyone had
i think maybe the ultimate forgotten
ones are the ones who exist
but are forgotten it feels like you
forgot about that the article
is about a almost 40 year old
philosophical idea
that if a person would rather be alive
than dead
than the highest possible utility would
be to have a population as high as
possible and then the creator of that
idea said
what a terrible and repugnant idea and
this is a good way
of proving that pure utilitarianism
isn't perfect
that is an interesting idea
but it's not the idea in the headline or
the subhead and they manufactured a
discourse
that was nothing like the discourse that
the article intended to manufacture and
that manufactured discourse became a big
hot thing on twitter we can't be
surprised that these things happen when
they work but maybe they will work
less if we are more aware of them and we
do get more aware of these things as we
spend more time on the platforms
so the reality is that as new
communication platforms
happen whether that's radio or books or
plays
over time we develop cultural structures
to help us handle them without them
tearing society apart and eventually
they end up being that goods like nobody
wants to live in a world without books
and so like a majority of my being
believes that that's possible for the
internet but no piece of me understands
how we're gonna get there
which is not a comfortable feeling john
i'll see you on tuesday